hats Cody Simpson visiting Miley Cyrus
in the hospital a hunt Tuesday she was
admitted for a case of tonsillitis but
big news here folks Miley called Cody
her bf in her Instagram story yeah take
a look at this pic her caption quote bf
coming to visit me at the hospital a
posted this a pic of Cody arriving with
guitar and roses in hand and if you
think that's cute
it gets cuter Cody snuggled Miley in bed
you can't take this guy anywhere
nope you can take this day anyway rip
some Elvis everywhere I go and he
serenaded her
[Music]
now here's the kicker the son Cody sings
is actually a son he wrote for Miley she
wrote quotes this sweet guy came to
visit at the hospital and sang the
sweetest song he wrote chess for me now
we know all these PDA posts might seem
like a bit much but Miley seemingly
wants to help Cody promote his music on
this video she said the song is quote
too special to be only heard in full by
my ears so I am currently pressuring him
to drop it next week and it's working
hashtag golden thing so maybe we'll get
this new track called golden thing next
week of course Miley and Cody have had
kind of a rollercoaster week or so fans
spotted them kissing at a smoothie shop
just last week it sent fans into a
tailspin because to some it seemed a
little fast after her divorce from Liam
Hemsworth and then her whirlwind romance
with Caitlin Carter Miley was having
none of that though addressing the
haters on Instagram in part writing
quote men especially successful ones are
rarely slut-shamed
they move on from one beautiful young
woman to the next most times without
consequence amid all this news though a
source told et that Miley and Cody have
no plans to start dating each other
exclusively and of course they've been
friends for years in fact back in 2014
we talked to Cody and even then he had
Miley's back she's definitely like a
very like at heart a very very sweet
normal black girl from Nashville like
and we were spending on a ranch in
Nashville and she's just like I'm just
like a lot of people say these things
like that you know she's just like the
coolest Jake yeah how's that for a
throwback anyways for all the latest on
Miley and Cody make sure that you stick
with et until next time I'm Katie Krauss
and Byford
[Music]
[Applause]
you